Speaker 1: All right. Let's check out what
some of you had to say about this week of
shows. You can always email info at David
Pacman dot com. But Facebook messages, you
Tube comments, tweets, smoke signals, telegrams
and snail mail may occasionally be included.
The first message today comes from Facebook.
I could give you a hundred of these every
single Friday, but it is simply one. You're
an imbecile. Of course the wrong your tool,
which our team knows. You simply write back
with the correct your y0u apostrophe r e,
and then we move on. From there we probably
get 8 to 10 of these a day and probably hundreds
via YouTube comment. Obviously, education
a concern in the United States. We're not
making fun of people who lack access to a
good education. What I am pointing to is maybe
don't call other people stupid morons, imbeciles,
etc. When you send a three word message and
one of those three words is just the wrong
word. Okay, so that's my advice. It's not
about making fun of people. Please, let's
just. Let's keep it together, folks. Okay?
The bread table comments about DeSantis and
says he's only a good candidate by comparison
to Trump speaking about Biden, I mean, I think
Dems are in serious trouble if it's DeSantis
versus Biden. I don't like the Santos personally,
but I think he's a very effective right wing
propagandist and looks better to the average
American voter than to old guys. Keep in mind,
the average voter doesn't have hard set policy
stances and votes largely on outward appearance,
social image and perception. Listen, I don't
know if you've been watching the first two
weeks of the DeSantis president presidential
campaign. He's not an effective propagandist.
His appearance and social image are a disaster.
He couldn't be less charismatic. He couldn't
be more awkward. He's doing the bobblehead
stuff. He used the word woke seven times in
28 seconds in a clip that we looked at on
Monday. If that's a guy who's relying on his
outward appearance to get elected, I think
he's in trouble, folks. I really do. Mr. Hipster
Posted to the David Pacman Show Subreddit
EU. David, why would you go to Florida for
the beaches? California is leagues better,
Florida is trash. California beaches are infinitely
better and way more ecologically diverse.
Couple different things I want to mention
here. Number one, California overall has much
more beautiful beaches from the standpoint
of scenery. I'm with you. The downsides to
California beaches are that I like to go in
the water and I just don't have it in me to
go in the freezing water of the Pacific. And
everybody, any time you say this to people
in California, they say, Oh, no, you go you
go down to Manhattan Beach and the water's
warm, it's warm. And then I step in there
and my foot turns blue. I'm too old for this
crap, guys. Okay? As a kid, I did it. I want
to be able to just kind of walk right in.
This is why I prefer, like, Aruba and Mexico.
But as far as the United States goes, the
southern tip, just the very extra tip there
of Florida is a good spot. And I have to say,
in the summer, it's hard to find nicer beaches
on the East Coast than Pensacola, although
technically Pensacola is in the Gulf. I understand
that. But warm, even warmer than over in Miami.
So, listen, like I'm with you about the beauty
of it all in California, the whole thing.
But if I want to go in the water, it's just
too damn cold. Okay. Please, please. Candy
Hoarding, commented Trump 2024. He pisses
off the establishment. So that's the one we
need for the people. This is perfect. As I've
told you many times before. There is a category
of maggots or maggot donations as the new
term may be that doesn't care about policy,
doesn't care about ideas, doesn't care about
what's good for them or their neighbors or
whatever they care about, quote, owning the
libs. And so they think if liberals are mad,
if liberals don't like Trump, it must be good
for the people. It's an incredibly childish
and pathetic way to analyze what we should
be doing in terms of American politics with
elections and thinking about what sort of
policy would be good or bad. But this is what
Candy hoarding says. Trump because the establishment
doesn't like him. Most people don't like him.
I hate to break it to you, but yes, but 40%
of Republicans still like him, and that might
be enough to win. Johnny X says it's ridiculous.
But at the same time, I don't want LGBT characters
in my kids media. I know they exist, but that's
not something kids should be exposed to until
they are teenagers. Think about how stupid
this is. Seriously? Seriously. You know, now,
as a parent, I start to think about things
like, okay. When my daughter is three, inevitably
she's going to look around and see that there
are kids who have a mom and a dad and kids
that have two moms and kids that have two
dads. And so she's going to be aware of the
fact that there are these different arrangements.
And so in what way would it benefit her or
anybody for me to go out of my way to make
sure that this never comes up like in school
or in media? She might see something on a
cartoon that mirrors reality. Oh, my goodness.
She shouldn't be exposed to that. And then
you're telling me when she's 13 now I go,
Listen. Some kids have two moms. That's a
ridiculous way to raise a kid. So I don't
really know what this person's talking about.
This person may not even actually have children
because it's very hard to imagine any way
in which it would be damaging to be aware
of the fact that there are LGBT people. Really,
really wacky stuff. And we got a lot of comments
about this. The guitar is Love wrote. Never
really understood how being gay goes against
the family unit. You can be gay and still
have a family. It happens all the time. Honestly,
I don't think these people actually care about
conservative or Christian values. I think
they're just homophobic. I agree with that.
I agree with that. The family unit is damaged.
If there is someone who is gay. Gay people
are part of families and they have families.
It's only damaging if their family is homophobic
and kicks them out. Alberto Garcia is commenting
about my vaccination and says I doubt Pacman
took the jab, but if he did, then I am looking
forward to the day that it works on him so
humanity does not have to tolerate him anymore.
Two things. Number one, Monday we went very
specifically about the risk of death from
vaccines, and we looked specifically at different
vaccines. We have data on this stuff. I encourage
you if you care about reality, to check it
out. Secondly, I doubt Pacman took the jab.
There are people in the audience who think
I'm playing a character on the show. That
happens all the time. But where people run
in I've said a million times now, I've told
you what my vaccination situation is with
the COVID vaccine and I've been vaccinated.
Why on earth would I lie about that? Why?
Who would? I don't know. Who would I even
be serving? What would be the point? I'm not
playing a character on this show. I just tell
you the things as they are. Please. RJ Kerry
about growing Christian nationalism in the
United States and discussions about transgender
identity and so many different things. RJ
Carey says, It always cracks me up when people
who do believe that a virgin can give birth
to a supernatural figure, lecture others about
biology and what is natural. LOL very much.
Well said RJ. Very, very much. Well said.
You know, in general, with the biblical morality
types, I would even go further than this.
Sometimes, you know, they'll call me and they'll
say, David, without the Bible, without this,
without this structure, how do you know what's
right and wrong? What's to stop you from just
killing people if you don't have some some
source that says it is wrong to kill or it
is wrong to murder. There's a distinction
between kill and murder made in some religious
texts. And when I hear that, I think to myself,
wait a second. Are you saying that were it
not for this supposed sacred text that communicates
to you what, in most cases a Jewish carpenter
in the sky wants you to do? Were it not for
that and the fear of eternal punishment as
a result of what that Jewish carpenter in
the sky wants you to do or not do. You'd be
murdering people like are you saying that
without that, you'd be murdering people? Because
if that's what you're saying, it doesn't make
a lot of sense to me. I don't need that to
tell me that murder is wrong. Anyway, it's.
I we don't have to. We don't have to get into
it. Here is someone reminiscing on when people
would say the Pledge of Allegiance. I'm pronouncing
it that way for a particular reason, Sylvia
Potter says. I remember when Republicans would
pray and say the Pledge of Allegiance before
they started their meeting, and we had a Bible
study before school started, and we never
had one school shooting that was never heard
of. Families like mine would sit around the
dinner table and pray before a bite of food
was eaten. We and a lot of other families
would get up every Sunday morning and go to
church, watch old news clippings back then
and the news today and tell me if you see
any difference and then tell me God doesn't
exist. You are the one with the big problem.
I am struggling to follow this, but I guess
the argument is when the Pledge of Allegiance
or allegiance was said in school and there
was Bible study in school, we didn't have
school shootings. We also had way fewer guns.
That's the first thing I would look at. We
had way fewer guns circulating at that time
and beyond. Before looking at the Pledge of
Allegiance, I would consider the tool that
is being used for the shootings. Before I
look at a Bible, I would consider the tool
that is being used for these shootings. But
folks, that this is America, folks like that
vote. And for every single one of them, we
need someone who's going to think critically
and rationally about the issues facing the
country and vote as well to cancel that out.
Otherwise, they will win. And that's a really,
really scary thing. We have a tremendous bonus
show for you today. Sign up at join Pacman
dot com. You'll get instant access and all
of the other great member benefits. You're
also doing a great thing to support the work
that we do. I'll see you on the bonus show.
If you're not a member, then sadly we will
not be reunited until Monday.
Unidentified: See you then.